okay and again so be as awkward as you
can um mark without getting a punch from
him
be as difficult as you can
right
so this you have a seat mark
so nigel can go as far as that
now what we got to do is we've got we're
going to look at the string rather than
nigel and he's going to pretend he's
doing she and aggie and we're going to
see if the string slackens
oh oh that went a bit tight then didn't
it over your head
all right could because even though i
said look at the string you actually saw
him go a little bit
did you if you did well done you see
that's a trouble you see you're all
critical
okay so let's do it again
so
whether you have a personal string now
see nigel doesn't want to
doesn't want to give in
to the form because he wants the form to
be really clear
and he's keeping his hand in front of
him
but
how much can you
okay so once more
right
this is how much sense he
oh
i've told the story several times
cytosensei in new zealand
he he got this knee down to throw this
suitcase around on the map we were
having a party
and he says no that's no good it's no
good then he had a few vodkas
and he gets up with a plastic fork and
he goes
grab the fork of course we all laugh
we're at a party it's all funny grab a
you know you don't grab a little plastic
he got he went really serious and
shouted at it grabbed the foot he says
to this person they grabbed the fork he
throws them i don't know several times
and he says he's holding the fork again
he says that's how much
power you need to do while my kiddo and
he just went like that and went big and
that broke in half and he said that's
how much you don't need
and i i still remember today thinking
it can't be
true what i've just seen so
nigel does this he keeps the string
tight because that's his main thought
but what he does is carry on
what he can do here it's getting a bit
tight now
so his best bet is to keep his hands
there but to let his body come towards
the chair move
go with your feet
yeah and with your feet that's it keep
the string tight
okay see
and now continue
but his stubborn mind
what we've all got
um jane thinks i'm worse than her but i
think she's worse than me so i don't
know who's right
so our stubborn mind is stopping us
actually seeing or doing the technique
correctly so let's do do it again so now
you know the format
right so
his body thank you his body is giving in
to the technique
rather than
him
being under
sort of pressure so now
so now you haven't got any string but
you've got a person who still weighs a
lot and do the sheer nag again
well you don't weigh that much but
so he has to somehow work out
how he
goes that's better
so we don't
um
we don't pin ourself
to the form and sometimes or most of the
time we do we go well it's there it's
there it's there and about and then
you'll see you'll hear what we call
unbendable arm then also this unbendable
arm gets to a bent arm and you're
getting shorter and some people can even
pull you back because
you are not realizing
and this technique you're doing i'm not
going to go into the depth of it but
when you
do that
when you do that
you're actually
not becoming supple enough you might
need to with your buttock you might need
to actually go into them a little bit
not giving anything you know so you
should be using the whole thing of
aikido you know people have been around
a long time you'll know you shouldn't uh
i don't know what the word was um
equilibrium yeah
balance equally you know
if i can see my hands
they need to be at the same distance if
that's where the distance is and i'll
bring it down here
then i haven't got aikido you know i've
got this what they call the unbendable
arm so if you're going to start off here
you might have to move into them
uh
if you're training with someone this
high and you're this high
forget she's an aggie it can't work oh
i'll bend my knees i'll be really good
it doesn't fit
it doesn't work
you need to only do sheer naggies really
on you know you might go bell and then
when they get up you go oh blimey
i didn't realize i was bound to you
go and find somebody else
all right so but if you can get somebody
similar height then you can do this a
shinagi all right so i'd like to just
switch now into the shia nagi
and see if you can keep
your arms
seeing your arms at the distance
and remember it's no good trying to see
your arms by dragging them around the
mat with you
i'm keeping my arms straight
yeah you have to you have to
bend like a the wind on a tree okay
don't want to go